sponsored by MailChimp
Yeah so basically this is our Flagship
product it's the Blinder 2.0 it's the
most revolutionary window blinds with
machine learning technology and yeah so
this is what you'll be working on got it
okay so we're a window treatment company
no we're a tech company
how we make window blinds well we we
sell them on a website so the that's
Tech
anyway we have a stand-up meeting with
this here in like a minute is there a
meeting link or
my god did you unlock the door
oh it's fine this is our CEO
in our apartment we have a problem we
have seen a decline in sales of the
Blinder 2.0 and it can't possibly be
because of the product so it has to be a
marketing issue
all right brainstorm go
oh we could do
don't interrupt me
I got it
we need to do email marketing oh
MailChimp is great for that email
marketing on it okay so so we're gonna
have to build the email server and then
oh shoot wait we gotta design a mail
transfer protocol should we do that in
TCP or UDP or maybe even make a new
Protocol no way
that's not enough
we have a lot of customers like
definitely more than
10.
so it won't be sustainable to email
every one of them individually so we
need some sort of we need some kind of
system and an automated system maybe
like
email automation
oh my God can we pen that
that's not new wait no
what if we made a whole platform to help
you create these email marketing
campaigns and automations okay now
you're literally just describing
MailChimp it's getting kind of complex
so I think we're gonna have to build a
team of network Engineers back-end
Engineers front end product managers
designers writers
um I I could start with the architecture
right away
um yeah I think we'll have to have
multiple email servers because this is
not a system design interview okay this
is real life so just use a service like
MailChimp you know they've already got
the infrastructure they handle 12
million customers and they send about
half a billion emails every day
wait why'd I notice
we also need machine learning that is a
must I mean we're not a tech company if
we don't have machine learning am I
right so what can we do we could train
models using our own data
how much data do we have
um
like seven
what does that even mean you could train
it with that right MailChimp analyzes
data from billions of emails they
already have personalized
recommendations that can increase our
engagement and our Revenue
billions versus seven
way
I think I got a brilliant idea
what if we use MailChimp
wait is he serious this is a joke right
that's genius oh God this is why your
CEO let me crank up some numbers
oh my God we're gonna save Millions from
our original plan what were you waiting
for go on mailchim.com to get started oh
right sorry
now with all that money saved what are
you gonna do
I have a couple of ideas
[Music]
[Music]